good place for discussion we've got fox
news contributor and former obama
economic advisor robert wolf screen
left and screen right member of the
trump white house economic recovery task
force stephen moore who's waving right
there good morning guys steve
good morning hey robert so uh we heard
joe biden say
absolutely it's okay to raise taxes
during the pandemic
listen the way i would look at it is one
he said no one will be touched under
four hundred thousand
if you look at his tax plan a
predominant of the
tax reform hits those that make over a
million and much more over three million
if you make between four hundred
thousand eight hundred thousand go from
twenty five to twenty five and a half
percent
if you look at his plan which is about 2
trillion of relief
and then 3 trillion of new spending he's
literally going to pay for his new
spending
and the rest is going to be in relief
similar to what we're talking about
today on capitol hill
i think it's the right plan it hits
about 1.3 trillion
of the trump tax reform which is
predominantly only the wealthy
and i think we have to look at it like a
patriotic tax like we do post war
this pandemic has been a war and people
like you stephen like me we
have to pay for it and i'm okay with
that you know i think uh if i
recall correctly that particular
question was asked by somebody who voted
for donald trump
last time around stephen do you agree
with uh robert that the middle class
will not feel any impact on a tax
increase well first of all i just wish i
were
as rich as robert is i wish i had a
penny for every dollar
robert but uh look we did the tax cut as
you know
uh steve i helped design that tax cut uh
when
donald trump came into office and people
like robert and people uh
you know like vice president joe biden
said it would be a mistake it wouldn't
work it would hurt the economy
and and we now have the results right
that we
we brought the unemployment rate down to
the lowest level
in history for blacks and hispanics we
saw huge wage gains
for americans uh robert we saw the
poverty rate in the united states fall
to its lowest level in the history of
the united states that means
there were a smaller percentage of poor
people two years after we did our tax
cut
than any time in american history in
other words it was a spectacular success
why in the world would you want to
repeal it i mean democrats talk a lot
about science we did the science we did
the experiment
it worked and yet it's it this seems to
me to be a kind of triumph
over ideology over what really works and
by the way the reason it works see this
is important those people that vice
president
biden is talking about that are going to
pay all these higher taxes
most of them are small business men and
women right how are you going to create
more jobs if you're taxing the
businesses that create the jobs i just
don't get it
well the question was uh regarding
whether or not it was smart to raise
taxes during a pandemic
and as robert said only people over uh
four hundred thousand dollars
but they're small business owners
they're small business owners well there
you go
regarding the pandemic though uh when
you look at
if you divided america into red states
and blue states
uh it turns out the unemployment rate
in the red states right now
is a average is about 6.6 percent
whereas
in blue states robert it is about
10.5 so four percent higher
what is going on in the red states that
is not going on
in the blue states well the states want
it very different first of all
the three largest cities in the country
new york city los angeles and chicago
has absolutely been
impacted by the pandemic number two
tourist and destination places
like nevada and las vegas or like
hawaii have been impacted those are blue
states and then if you look at these
uh blue states they also have the most
diverse demographics
and we knew that the black and brown
community has been
impacted the most the gap in
unemployment between
white males and hispanics and african
americans
has gapped dramatically during this
pandemic so this is not a surprise
every state is not built the same every
state has different demographics
this is not a surprise to anyone as
steve
would look at the states are very
different as are the cities
stephen do you agree with that analysis
so people should go to my video uh six
million views on where do you want to
live
basically the problem in america is just
you know you go to chicago i'm from
chicago
i go to new york city the mayors and the
governors of those states have destroyed
our great great cities by shutting down
by the way andrew cuomo after all of
this is now locking down new york again
i mean how crazy is that by the way
steve you now have texas florida georgia
utah
idaho south carolina red states are open
for business they're balancing their
budgets blue states are a disaster
let's not make america look more like
new york let's make america look more
like texas in florida
so what have we learned today we've
learned those uh points of view but we
also learned that steven's got a video
that's been seen six million times and
robert is really rich
and he lives in a blue state all right
guys thank you very much we'll see you
now okay thanks steve
thank you